you know at the end of the day they
always say it is a it is a game and
often times cooler heads prevail and you
even yourself have said you get
hot-headed at times do you think that is
something that might have worked against
you um I don't I mean I do get
passionate about things and when I
wanted to complete a specific thing I
really put my all into it so the
hotheadedness I thought was tempered
enough you know in the speech especially
that it was just a really truthful
professional kind of speech other times
in that I think it was was okay but I'm
not quite sure yeah
you know Derrick voted for you in Paris
actually voted against you right do you
think that Derrick's loyalty is gonna be
something that will be a detriment to
him moving forward knowing what you know
right but you really can't trust people
sure absolutely I mean Dayla as a as a
duo are in danger right now so Derrick
throwing me a vote I think is as totally
fair there wouldn't be a bigger target
if you didn't throw him his vote for me
right so I think that they're in trouble
regardless yeah so you know when you're
playing this game you're in the house
the relationships with teammates the
relationships with people that people
are like people were shipping you in
Paris a lot right right and then you
know Olivia came in and and things got a
bit mixed up did you let your heart get
in the way of what your head knew to be
the right decisions I'd not to play
emotionally throughout so I tried not to
really get into to show show Matt
showmance
you know situations because you know
ultimately we're here for a game we're
here to get ourselves farther and I felt
like I made moves that way that weren't
so emotionally affiliated yeah what
would you do differently if there's
thing you could have changed about the
way you play the game what would you do
I think I needed to spend more time with
a couple different people to make sure
that I had better rapport with them over
you know what Derek and Kayla kind of
you know not exclusively but mostly
because that obviously painted too big
of a target for me to come back from
yeah you know when hamza said he wanted
to blow up the whole things but the
house you look like you were just
shocked just shot like what were the
biggest surprises for you when you were
actually in there i mean the biggest
surprise was was being nominated this
week I was given a minute heads up and
that's not a lot of time to get prepared
so that was the biggest shock other than
that the most shocking things were
people not understanding sound logic
when it's pitch to them right so I'm
saying you know there's a group of four
or five working on this other side of
the house we need to come together right
now to make sure I don't leave or you
guys are gonna be in trouble so I guess
we're gonna see what happens over the
next couple of weeks but that's really
the most frustrating part of all this
yeah so given given that all that has
fallen apart things are going in a very
different direction what do you see
happening moving forward like who do you
think has the upper hand who do you
think is gonna be on the chopping block
and who do you think will surprise the
viewers yeah I think you know right now
it depends on who wins this next HOH
whether it be someone on on a hands
aside or you know a derecho kala that
win they might target each other
I think Johnnie is a good chance you
know a Johnnie Erika if they can make
the right little group they have a good
chance moving forward because they could
you know split into different social
circles and and kind of play under the
radar even when they're kind of threats
so yeah it's gonna be exciting I don't
know what's gonna happen it's really
impossible to protect especially after
this week yeah it's oh yeah being in
your spot right now it must have thrown
you for a loop I mean just to say the
least
and I'm sure you were you know salty
coming out of the house yeah what are
your feelings towards towards the people
that you had allied yourself with today
like this morning how are you feeling
about that I mean it's it's gonna be
extremely tough to get over this because
it was such a like a disgustingly
premature exit right so it's unfortunate
they couldn't see the reasoning and I
mean I hope it works out for them but
yeah you know it's tough to just look
past that right now yeah and it's so
fresh
are you like are you really pissed like
are you upset with Paris are you you
must be kind of pissed at Hamm's I'm
sure um you know as a game player I do
respect hamza so I said good one you
know as I was leaving he made the right
play for his game and it worked out but
you know I'm more mad at the people that
should have made the move to help
themselves be in a better position in
the game right so you know when we're
talking about Paris I'm not mad at her
individually mm-hm
you know it's more of the group thing
that everyone can give a commitment and
then the whole thing just didn't happen
right so all right so what you do now
what are you gonna do what do I do now
I'm going back to Saskatoon no we're
gonna try to live that normal life again
and see see what happens I mean it's
only been three weeks so yeah are you
gonna be online just like constantly
following what's going on letting people
know what you think strategy is that
like will people be able to turn to you
to kind of get an inside look at me but
what could be happening in the house
downline absolutely I cannot wait to get
my phone back I'm gonna be on that
Twitter app guys give me a follow cuz I
am so involved in this season I'm so
excited to see where it's going so I'll
be on Twitter a lot not man